we have a new Enterprise and normally
that would be very very exciting
but
I'm not sure I like how they did this
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
if you haven't seen the last episode of
Picard season three
before you watch this video please there
might be a couple of little spoilers so
turn the video off now and come back
once you've seen the episode and I have
to ask why haven't you seen it it's
brilliant anyway
if those people have now gone I could
talk about the Enterprise G so as we
know from the end of Picard season 3 the
Titan a has been re-christened the
Enterprise G
listen in honor of you and your crew
[Music]
we know that the Enterprise F The
Odyssey class was lost early
decommissioned because of some encounter
with something or other we know this
because it was actually an Easter egg
early on in season three
so the Odyssey class a vessel I
absolutely adored and I love the history
of where that ship came from coming from
the game Etc we only saw her very
briefly but at least she did become
Canon
now there are some designs for the
Enterprise G from Again The Wider Cannon
and they're very very cool I'm going to
show you one example here it's actually
the eclipse class and
I would have loved to have seen the
Enterprise go something maybe more this
way but they've renamed the Titan a and
re-christened the Enterprise this was
really to celebrate Picard and the
Enterprise and their part in Saving the
fleet and really saving the Federation
but I do have a couple of problems with
that one
the Titan a basically got its ass handed
to it the entire series
it was basically sure when they saw the
strike for the first time when we are
not a vessel that can go up against this
we're not a warship we are an
exploration vessel shouldn't the
Enterprise the most famous vessel in the
fleet and what normally gets described
as the flagship of the fleet be one of
the more capable vessels of the fleet
obviously the nx01 the first warp 5
capable vessel built by Humanity was
called the Enterprise the Enterprise
ncc-1701 was one of the most capable
warships in the fleet it's safe the
Federation multiple times particularly
in the refit in the motion picture we
saw that it had new shields vija wiped
out the Klingons without any effort at
all but the Enterprise with its new
shields was able to take a hit and keep
on coming we also know from the Search
for Spock that the Enterprise was the
fastest ship in the fleet that when the
captain of the Excel series sort of
mocking the Enterprise is saying we're
going to come and we're going to break
some of your speed records tomorrow so
the Enterprise refit ncc-1701 was the
fastest ship in the fleet and one of the
most capable warships but is an
Enterprise getting christened from
another vessel something that's happened
before well we think following the
destruction of the Enterprise the
original and we saw the Enterprise
ncc-1701 a that was virtually identical
come on our screens that it can't have
been a new ship it must have been
something that had already been
constructed maybe something that was
already in service because it was only a
few months after the destruction of the
Enterprise so was this actually a vessel
that was named something else originally
well there is one Theory and it is
theorized that it was actually the York
town and then it was re-christened the
Enterprise a so this maybe has happened
before
for me the flagship of the fleet should
be the most capable of vessels and it
does seem that every other Enterprise
that followed the a was but you could
argue that perhaps the a wasn't that it
continued to be a constitution class
mainly because that was Kirk's ship The
Excelsior class had already been
construction and was a superior vessel
in virtually every way
so really the Enterprise a should have
been an Excellency class if you can
continue along that idea of it being the
most capable vessel in the fleet The
Odyssey class again was bigger than the
e a more capable fighting machine again
designed with the Borg in mind and
things like the Scimitar from the
romulans it was a warship I don't think
you can call the Titan a that but that
vessel was an important ship in the
defense of the fleet so we naming it the
Enterprise is a great honor but isn't
that also a kind of snubbing your nose
at the Titan the Titan was just as
important in the defense of the
Federation during Picard season 3 as the
Enterprise the Enterprise D just came in
at the end and saved the day the Titan
was the vessel that defeated the strike
that came in and through using the
cloaking technology Etc was able to give
the Enterprise D time to defeat the Borg
it took on the entire fleet
and the fact that it is the Titan a
does suggest actually the Titan is a
name that already has importance within
the Federation because it has been
argued that they only give that suffix
of the a b c d Etc two vessels that have
that importance
so it was already an important name
within the Federation and they just
completely ignored everything it had
done and re-christened it the Enterprise
it seems like
a bit of an insult I don't really
understand why they did it now
coming away from Let's Pretend Star Trek
isn't real for a second why did the
writers do it well we look like we are
going to be getting Starfleet Legacy
this whole end sequence was set up for
that and there seems to be an obsession
with writers that
a Star Trek series like this has to be
based around the Enterprise
Star Trek Enterprise with Scott Bakula
Captain Archer Etc
should never have been called the
Enterprise
the Enterprise with Kirk ncc-1701 was
always called to being the first
Enterprise now the writers of that
series got around that by saying well I
said nx01 it's not really Starfleet it's
a experimental vessel so you know
technically we it isn't the first ship
the Enterprise is still the first but
that all seemed to me a cop out to me
they should have just called it the
Endeavor or the Atlantis or something
like that then you know I wouldn't have
been a bit mild by the fact that it was
the Enterprise they didn't need to do it
and for me Star Trek Legacy have done it
again they didn't mean to change the
name to the Enterprise they could have
done this brilliant scene at the end
Captain seven of nine aboard the Titan a
about to go on its first mission and as
it does it flies past
the new Enterprise G they could have
done seen a little bit like the end of
Undiscovered Country
where the Excelsior and the Enterprise
are flying together the Nick Celsius
flies away and they said oh my God
that's a big ship and it says not as big
as their Captain they could have done
something like that I'd have loved to
say maybe data as Captain or something
but they didn't do that and I do think
it's a shame in lots of ways but
this whole end sequence happened a whole
year after the events of the Borg attack
so we can assume can't we that the
Titans had a massive refit Perhaps it is
a far more capable vessel now than it
was when we saw it earlier now we're not
going to know whether that's true or not
until we actually see this vessel in
action I'm going to do a video talking
about Legacy a little bit later but I
think is pretty much nailed down to
happen I just hope it doesn't continue
being a vessel that you know is a Plucky
Underdog and gets his ass handed to
every two minutes I want to see a vessel
that can actually take on some of the
villains in Star Trek but guys what do
you think I love the whole ending
sequence I love how it sets up Legacy it
just frustrates me and I put a poll on
my channel and I basically said was it
okay to rename the Titan to give us a
new Enterprise 52 percent of you said
yes but 48 of you said no and that is
after 1400 votes by the way and it's
still that close so this is going to be
a little bit of a contentious issue
should we care probably not but with
trekkies we do will it be cool to see
seven of nine of captain of the
Enterprise yeah very cool
if they were going to rename the Titan
to celebrate Picard in his career
couldn't they have called it the USS
Picard maybe I just think they went too
far calling it The Enterprise
but guys give the comments to what you
think is this okay or is it actually
one more little mistake in Picard season
three that again doesn't take anything
away from a brilliant series but is
maybe a little bit irritating get into
the comments tell me exactly what you're
thinking if you are new to the channel
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps out and you'll
never miss any of our new videos also
you can go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
go first and you can watch them without
the adverts for a small contribution
each month
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]